newly released body camera video shows
the moments leading up to a deadly
officer-involved shooting in California
after a man pulled a weapon on sheriff's
deputies hey don't reach for it
don't reach for it
hey get on the ground
hey don't reach for it
get on the ground
get on the ground then on August 7th Los
Angeles County sheriff's deputies in the
Carson station received a 9-1-1 call
reporting a disturbance at a Chevron gas
station personal sheriff station Jackson
speaking how can I help you
over here
what store are you at
material repetition what's the address
of course
Central Avenue New Castle the store
clerk told dispatch a man at the gas
station later identified as 34 year old
Arturo serones was screaming at gas
pumps and refused to leave
um what's happening there
people die
they touching like a crazy screaming
outside
and so I want you to live for you
screaming I'm walking around the door
video shows First Responders arrived to
the scene to confront cernas
hey you need to go dude
what are you doing here
huh
start
almost immediately officials notice
sirness has what appears to be the butt
of a handgun sticking out of his pocket
what's your pocket hey hey put your
hands up put your hands up what is it
put your hand what is it Hey listen hey
bro put your hands up hey deputies then
call for cernest to get to the ground
don't reach for it
[Applause]
hey don't reach for it get on the ground
get on the ground then get on the ground
hey get on the ground
Hey listen get on the ground
after that video shows a first responder
take cover behind a squad car still
calling for cernest to get down
yeah
what's the address here
open the door
[Applause]
[Laughter]
get on your knees
security camera video shows sereness
kneeling on the ground while officials
instructed him not to reach for anything
video shows their nests reach into both
his pockets and backpack by this time
officers had taken covers so the view
from their body cameras was obstructed
they can be heard though calling for
cernas to leave his belongings alone
hey put your hands on your hood
Hey sir in the car hey you want to back
up
yeah
hey stop reaching in your pocket no keep
your hands on there on your head
no keep your hands on your head
leave your phone alone
stop reaching
after this their nest reaches for the
weapon in his back pocket that's when
multiple officials open fire one with a
less lethal 40 millimeter weapon and the
other seconds later with a department
issued gun
I'm gonna get him with the 40 that goes
in his pocket
this is left pocket right yeah
leave your hands on your head
after that sheriff's deputies again call
for Sarah Ness to put his hands on his
head leave your hands on your head
listen
here hey let's get fires fire Sage
[Music]
after the shooting First Responders gave
sereness medical assistance but he was
pronounced dead before he could be taken
to the hospital officials also recovered
a BB pistol that resembled a gun on the
scene the shooting is now under
investigation by both the Los Angeles
County Sheriff's Department homicide
unit and the Los Angeles County District
Attorney's Office reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie